MAYURESH SAOJI: Hello
everyone.
Thank you for coming to the
Content API for Shopping
session at Google I/O. My
name is Mayuresh Saoji.
I am a product manager on the
Google Shopping team, and I'm
going to be co-presenting this
session along with Daniel
Hermes, who's from the Developer
Relations team.
Today we're going to talk about
a bunch of stuff in the
next 60 minutes or so.
I'm just going to set some
context for this session by
providing an overview for Google
Shopping and just want
to make sure that everyone
is in sync.
This maybe repetitive for some
of you in the crowd, but
please bear with me
for a few minutes.
After that, I'm going to
turn it over to Danny.
Danny is going to go very deep
into the Content API.
He's going to talk a lot about
the mechanics of the Content
API, so how you do stuff,
how you actually form
a request, et cetera.
And he's going to also spend a
significant amount of time on
probably the most important part
of the session, which is
how can you use the tools that
we have and use the Content
API to really improve your
data quality and send us
better quality feeds.
So without further ado,
let's get started.
So let me tell you first a
little bit about how we use
the product data that you send
to us using the Content API.
So the point I'm trying to make
here is that you have one
Feed, but it's repurposed into
multiple destinations, and I'm
going to talk a little
bit about these
destinations first.
So the first and obvious
destination is Google
Shopping, right?
So the data that you send us
through the Content API or
Twitter feeds through the
Merchant Center obviously
appears on Google Shopping.
Let me show you what
this looks like.
So I've done here a query for
Rocky Mountain River Race
Water Slide, and you see
some results here.
When I click on these results,
I'm going into a search
results page for shopping and
then clicking through into a
product page where I can then
compare prices and look at
things like that.
So that's one place
where you can--
actually, you know what,
this didn't work as it
was supposed to.
I don't know what happened
to the URL there.
PRODUCER: OK, start.
You want to pick up
where [INAUDIBLE].
MAYURESH SAOJI: Sure.
Can I start?
PRODUCER: So we're doing
a pick-up here.
MAYURESH SAOJI: Pick up here.
OK.
Let me tell you a little
bit about the different
destinations.
The first and most obvious one
is Google Shopping, so the
feeds that you send us are
manifested on Google Shopping.
Let me show you what
that looks like.
So I did a search for Rocky
Mountain River Race Inflatable
Water Bouncer, and you see
the results over here.
When I click over here, I get
into the search results page
on Shopping and then clicking
through on one of these
results will take me into
the actual, oh, sorry.
I know what I did wrong.
OK, I'm going to do
it one more time.
Sorry about that.
OK, so the first and obvious
place where the most obvious
place where your search results
appear, sorry, where
your product feeds appear
are on Google Shopping.
The data that you sent to us is
manifested on Google Shopping.
So here I've done a search for
Rocky Mountain River Race,
which is an inflatable
water raft.
And, as you can see here, there
are several listings on
the search results page.
Clicking on one of these takes
me to a product page, where I
can then look at different
products and different sellers
for that product,
and so forth.
So that's one obvious
place where your
data manifests itself.
The second place is on Google
Commerce Search.
So Commerce Search
is a product that
we've created for retailers.
Several retailers are already
using this product
successfully.
And what Google Commerce Search
allows you to do is to
bring the search and discovery
experience that you get on
Google to your retail website.
So as an example there, I'm on
the Baby Age website, and as I
search for Rocky Mountain River
Race, you see that I see
these examples or suggestions of
products that I can go to.
And the product here in fact
has an image, a title, a
price, and so forth.
And then clicking on one of
these takes me to the actual
product in place, right?
So you get all of the power of
Google Search, but on your
retail website.
The third destination
that I want to talk
about is Google Shopper.
So Google Shopper is a mobile
app created for Android and
the iPhone and basically allows
you to expose your
products, not only on
the desktop, but
also on mobile phones.
So this is another place where
we repurpose your data.
I'm not going to bother with
trying to figure out
projection equipment, et cetera,
for mobile phones.
So I just took a couple of
screen caps here which
illustrate what this
looks like.
So on the left there you see
what the search results page
looks like, and then on the
right you actually see the
details on a specific
product page, right?
So those are the different
destinations where we manifest
data from your product feed.
Next, I want to talk a little
bit about how we use the data
that you send us to improve
the shopping experience.
So I'm going to use
again an example.
Let's say I'm a computer
aficionado, like building
computers, and I'm trying to
buy random access memory.
I'm trying to buy some RAM.
I do a search for random
access memory.
Of course I get some search
results here, but what if I'm
trying to find something
very specific?
This is where these filters are
queried on the left side,
on the left nav come
into play.
So I can look for a certain
price range.
I can look for a brand.
I can look for DDR2 or 3.
I can look for a particular
form factor, or a memory
capacity, or so forth.
So we understand the facets of
this product, and we can
expose them here on the left
side for you to look at and to
further restrict your search.
So if I click on two to four GB,
it indicates that's what
I'm searching for and now the
search results are different.
So it's a very useful feature
for you to kind of hone in on
what you're exactly
trying to find.
Let me give you another
example.
I'm taking a trip to Argentina
later in the summer, which is
our summer but their winter
so I hear it's cold there.
I want to buy jacket.
I like tan jackets.
I did a search for
brown jacket.
Now there are some search
results here, not exactly
useful for me because there are
men's and women's jackets.
So I can go here, go to the left
nav again, and I see that
one of the filters, one of the
facets here is gender.
So if I click on men's jackets,
now all of the
results that I see are
men's jackets.
So again, very useful.
Of course, I can also further
filter this based on color, or
price, or what have you.
And then another interesting
improvement, or another
interesting feature that we've
launched is this concept of
visually similar items.
So if I go into one of these
search results, you see
immediately below here that we
show visually similar items,
same color, same cut, and so
forth to the search item that
I was looking at.
So again, a very useful
tool to inspire
people to discover stuff.
And especially when you're not
sure of what you're looking
for, this could be something
very useful.
So the point here is that we
ask you for a lot of data.
We ask you for a lot
of information.
And it's not just price and
title and availability and
image and so forth.
We ask you for things like brand
and color and variance
and things like that.
In case you're wondering why do
you do that, this is why.
It really allows us to provide
a rich user experience.
And it allows us to make sure
that users are able to
navigate and filter and
find exactly what
they're looking for.
So that's how we use the data
that you give us to improve
the shopping experience.
So now let me spend a couple
minutes talking about the
Content API proper before
I turn it over to Danny.
The Content API really allows
you to open the firehose and
pump all your product data into
Google very efficiently,
very quickly.
Let me talk about some of the
benefits of the Content API.
First and foremost, the
Content API for
Shopping is real time.
What does that mean?
Basically, the latency for
you to submit data to us
is very, very low.
There is the express pipeline,
which allows you to send us
data and make incremental
updates.
So if you only want to change
price and availability, and if
you only want to change it for,
let's say 5% of the items
that you send us, you can do
so very quickly and very
efficiently.
So real-time feedback, real-time
data, entry real
time, sort of updates to your
product inventory, to your
product price, attributes that
change very often, just much
faster than submitting
a feed to us.
The second benefit is
that the Content API
for Shopping is automated.
This allows you to
operate at scale.
So for instance, the feedback
format for each item is
identical to the submission
format.
So what that means is, it's
very easy for you to write
parsers and so forth for the
script, for this data.
You get errors back to you as
they happen, so they replay to
you as they happen.
And it's very granular.
It's not sort of at a digest
level, or an aggregate level.
You can get very granular
information
on what went wrong.
An example of how this would
be useful is if you set up
your ERP system to connect
directly to the Content API.
Let's say I have
an ERP system.
All your inventory
data is in there.
And what you can do is you can
set up some kind of automated
script, or a cron job, or
whatever, to go into that
database, get your inventory and
information, and then pipe
it through to the Content API
and send it over to Google.
So as stuff changes in your
database, it can be picked up
by our scripts and it'd be
piped through the API.
And it could be sent to us
pretty much in real time.
And then once we get it, we
can process it and very
quickly push it out.
So the latency is very,
very quick, so
automated and real time.
So here's a quick comparison
for when is the Content API
appropriate.
So again, just to recap, you can
send us data in two ways,
through a simple feed, flat
file, XML file, through the
Merchant Center, or you can
use the Content API.
On the feed side, typically
these are used by smaller
merchants with static
product inventories.
So inventory doesn't
change that often.
Certainly, price and
availability and things like
that don't need to be
updated as often.
The benefit here is that
it's easy to set up.
Minimal initial input
is needed.
On an ongoing basis, you
don't really need
much technical inputs.
So it's easy to set up
and to maintain.
On the other hand, the Content
API for Shopping, merchants
with larger, more dynamic
inventories tend to use this.
There is some initial effort
you need to invest in this
from a technical standpoint, but
again the payoff is huge
if you need it.
If you're looking to have a real
time system, have a way
to get us data quickly, and
automate everything, then this
is definitely for you.
But based on the fact that all
of you are here now in the
audience, I'm assuming that the
Content API is something
that you are either using or
thinking of using for your
particular use case
and these are good
trade-offs to think about.
So now let me turn it off to
Danny from DevRel, and he's
going to talk a little bit about
how you can leverage the
Content API and really use it
to your advantage, and scale
and improve your data quality.
Thank you.
DANNY HERMES: Thanks,
Mayuresh.
So before I can get to the thing
that you all came here
to see today, how to improve
your data quality, I'm first
going to review how you can
use the API mechanically.
So, as you see here, we
have a sample request.
It's XML.
We have some various pieces of
product data, like a title,
Swiss Champ, Swiss Army Knife,
a description, the most
complete Swiss army knife
available, and some other
pieces like an ID,
a condition, a
price, and a tax rule.
And all these pieces
are contained in a
parent entry element.
And that's how we describe
each individual product.
So in order to insert a product,
you're going to
submit a post request to the
URI content.goodleap
is.com/content/v1, and then
you're going to include your
account ID, then
/items/products/schema.
Now, you're including your
account ID to identify the
account that actually owns
this product data.
In addition to that, you're
going to send an authorization
header with the request that
you're signing the request
with to verify the actual
authenticated Google account
associated with this Merchant
Center account.
And then the third piece that
you need to send with your
request is the content type, and
that simply identifies to
Google that you're sending us
a certain type of content.
In this case that's XML.
OK.
So let's demo.
Let's actually see what this
looks like for an account.
So, I'll show you here my
account, my demo account,
Joe's Widgets, 8721349.
Right now this has no product
data at all in the account.
So let's use a tool
to actually insert
some product data.
So I'm not signed in.
I'm going to sign into
this demo tool.
OK, so now I have a token that
this tool can actually use to
sign the request.
And what's more, it went and got
my merchant ID associated
with the account for
Joe's Widgets, OK?
and from there it can actually
construct the URI that it
needs to make the insert
or post request.
OK, so let's insert a product.
So with the demo tool, you can
just totally ignore the XML
structure if you like and you
could just specify the title.
So here we see no name xx500,
just another widget that Joe
is going to sell.
And also notice we have this
warnings check box checked and
that adds just a little piece
to the end of the URI
warnings, which will give some
more warnings in the response
that we get from the API.
And just for those who are
curious, this is the
equivalent XML to the input
fields that we saw on the
other part.
So let's execute this request
and see what happens.
So it's a post like
we saw, same XML.
And the response come
back a 201.
Success.
And we get back various things,
like a location.
And of course as Mayuresh said,
the actual body the
response is almost identical
to the request the body the
request, and that's the
automated nature of this API.
So again, we have an entry, we
have the same title, have the
same description.
We have some various
other things like
a link to the item.
And then as we scroll down in
the App Control element, we
actually see the warnings
that we asked for.
So let's verify in my
account that this
insert actually worked.
So I'm going to refresh this
page and there you see it.
I went from zero products
to one product.
OK?
So this is one tool that you can
actually use when you're
starting out with an
implementation.
So another tool that we offer, a
series of open source client
libraries that we have
support for in Java,
Python, PHP, and .NET.
Now to give you an idea of how
these libraries work we'll see
some sample code.
So first, all these libraries
have a concept of a client or
a service object.
And this is sort of the work
course of the entire library.
These objects will create
the request.
They'll sign the request.
They'll help you do the
authentication so you can get
those tokens for
doing signings.
And of course they'll worry
about constructing the correct
XML and taking your data and
turning it into something that
the API can understand.
So in Python, we
simply use the
gdata.contentforshopping.client
module and import the content
for shopping client class.
And in order to instantiate an
instance of that class, we
simply need to pass in the
actual ID of the account to
the constructor via the keyword
argument account_ID.
And using that, the client will
then construct the URIs
when it makes API requests.
Similarly, in .NET, rather
than modules,
we have name spaces.
So using the
google.gdata.contentforshopping
name space, we get the content
for shopping service class.
And similar to Python, we just
get a new instance of that
class by giving it the account
ID as a string, as well as
another string, which will
identify the application, just
for logging purposes, but really
nothing beyond that.
And lastly, in PHP, rather than
name spaces and modules,
we just have a single
file which contains
all the data we need.
And so by requiring the
gshoppingcontent.PHP file, we
get the gsc_client class, which,
again, to instantiate a
new instance, simply takes
a string, which holds the
account ID.
So, in addition to having the
service object, the next most
important thing is
probably product
data and product entries.
So how do we represent product
entries using these libraries.
Again I'll start off
with Python.
Using the
gdata.contentforshopping.data
module, a similar
module to the
gdata.contentforshopping.client
module, we can import classes
which will actually abstract
away the XML behavior into
simple Python attributes.
So, to start out, we'll just
have an empty entry, which is
a member of the product
entry class
constructed with no arguments.
And to actually set the product
ID, for example, we
set the product_ID attribute of
this entry to an instance
of the product ID class where we
pass in the string that we
want to represent as the XML
value into the constructor or
product ID.
In .NET, we use the
google.gdata.con
tentforshopping.elements
name space.
And this name space has things
like a product entry class as
we saw for Python.
So to get a new product entry,
we just call new product entry
with no argument.
And the setters and getters for
.NET actually will do the
casting from strings into the
desired classes themselves, so
we don't even need to worry
about knowing the name of the
product ID class.
We just set this product ID
attribute to a string and
everything else is done
under the covers.
Similarly, for PHP, we start off
with an empty gsc_product
element, and we use the
SetSKUActual method on that
element and pass
in the string.
And that's the way the
setters and getters
work in the PHP library.
Let's actually use one
of these clients.
So for the rest of the code
samples, we use Python to keep
it simple since it reads like
pseudocode, in my opinion.
Without actually having product
data in hand, let's
just retrieve all the
products for our
account, for Joe's Widgets.
So assuming we have a shopping
client instantiated with my
account ID, and also with an
auth token, so I'm going to
leave out the authentication
part.
If you'd like to see more about
authentication, there
are some good talks here about
OAuth2 at Google I/O 2012.
But let's assume we've
done all this.
To actually get a feed of all
our products, we simply call
the GetProducts method with
no arguments on this
instantiated client.
And that variable feed will
contain an attribute entry
which is an interval list
containing all the products.
And so we could loop through
that list and print out the
title of each product to see a
snapshot of our inventory.
So what we expect from what we
saw on the Merchant Center is
that Joe's Widgets
has one product.
It's this no name x x,
et cetera, widget.
So let's actually use the
library under the covers to
execute this and see
what we get.
So there you have it, one
product, and it's the product
we just inserted using
the demo tool.
Great, so let's actually insert
a product using the
client library and see
what that looks like.
So assuming the variable entry
holds a product that we've
constructed, let's actually
assume it holds the product
that we constructed in that
sample XML, the Swiss Champ
army knife.
In order to insert it, we just
call the InsertProduct method
on the shopping client object.
And we'll get back an inserted
object which is very similar
to the entry that we inserted,
but it is a bit different, so
this is where the automated
part comes back in.
This is the exact same format,
and it's also an instance of
the product entry class, but
it's a bit different.
It has a few more things like
the published value and the
edited value and things
like that.
So, let's actually carry
this out, and see if
we get a 201 here.
Let's insert the product OK,
great, the insert worked.
We got a 201.
So now, going back to the
example from two slides past,
let's again get our product
feed, and loop through it and
see if it's changed.
Let's see if we see the Swiss
Champ army knife.
OK, there you have it.
The insert worked.
I wasn't lying to you.
Great.
So, now that we've reviewed
some of the tools that you
actually have in place to get
started with the Content API,
let's actually talk about how
you can improve the quality of
your data via best practices and
some debugging tools, as
well as some great data quality
tools that we have.
So, first, best practices, the
very first best practice I
want to talk about is using
APIs versus using feeds.
If you're using the API,
don't send updates
for your entire inventory.
Rather, just send updates
for things
that need to be updated.
If you come from the world of
feeds files, then when you
need to make an update of even
10 products out of 9,000, you
still need to send
your entire feed.
We don't have to do that here.
That's the value with the API.
You can simply send the updates
for the products that
need to be updated.
It's incremental rather than a
single upload of every product
that you have.
Next, don't mix feeds with
the Content API.
I won't say too much here other
than there's a lot of
undefined behavior when
you do this and it's
just not a good idea.
Really if you're going to
switch from feeds to the
Content API, by all
means switch.
Don't straddle the bridge
in between.
Third, make sure to update your
items before they expire.
Now this is similar to a point
I'm going to talk about a
little bit more in depth further
down this list, but it
deserves its own bullet
point for this reason.
The expiration date on a product
can be set to 30 days
post when it's inserted or
updated, and no further.
So that means if you don't
make any changes to the
product, at most 30 days later,
it's going to expire.
So you need to actually
be aware of when
products are expiring.
And if you want to keep it in
your inventory, you're going
to actually need to send just
an empty update, an update
with all the same data that you
already have, but either
explicitly set the expiration
date 30 days in the future, or
just send no expiration date and
by default the system will
set it to that same value.
Fourth, combine your item
updates into batch requests
whenever you can.
And the reason to do
this is because it
saves quota for you.
It saves the amount of requests
that you have to deal
with, and also collects
responses into batches of
responses in the exact
same automated
fashion that we saw before.
Finally, update items as
soon as they change.
This is a great feature.
Recall when Mayuresh
was talking
about the express pipeline.
By sending an update the second
you know there's a
price change, it will actually
surface through
to results in search.
And this is something that
benefits both you and people
trying to buy your products.
I want to go into a little bit
more in depth about this.
First, the value here is that
it keeps your data in sync
with our data.
And this is pretty big.
Like I said, if we're talking
about the experience of your
shoppers, we don't want them
to see something when they
actually go through Google, and
then go to your site and
see something different,
right?
Next, it avoids load spikes.
If you were to just wait to the
end of the day, or the end
of the week, or the end of the
month to send all your updates
and your inserts and your
deletes, then you would have
this huge spike and your system
may crash just because
maybe there's not enough
machines, not enough memory,
not enough processors.
You know?
So this avoids load spikes and
evens it out over really the
use of your inventory or your
merchants if you run a
marketplace.
And I just want to give a
small caveat to this.
Rather than sending an update
every time it happens, if they
are happening frequently enough,
it may make sense to
let them pool up into batches
and then send those batches
out maybe every five minutes
or something like this.
But still, relatively shortly
after these updates are
happening you should still be
sending them rather than, like
I said, having this load
spike pile up.
Speed bumps can occur.
Everything I've talked about
up until this point assumes
you won't make any mistakes.
You won't have any errors and
everything will work perfectly.
Well, that's not the
case, right?
Sometimes you miss a character
in your XML.
Sometimes you post
to the wrong URI.
Sometimes your token
expires, right?
Sometimes things go wrong.
So what can we do, and what's
provided for you to deal with
these occasions where
things go wrong.
So first, errors, error
feedback is
again an XML element.
This is structured very similar
to the entries that
you're sending and receiving
when you're making requests,
but rather than an apparent
entry element, we have
apparent errors element.
And so here, in this sample,
what we have is a condition
that was missing--
and condition is required--
as well as a price
that was missing.
And so what we get back in the
response is condition, is the
location of the error.
And the reason for
the error is that
it's a required attribute.
And so by using this, if your
database actually is aware of
the condition and aware of the
price, you can actually
without human intervention
fix this error.
So using the structure of the
errors, which is very similar
to the structure of the request
and responses, you can
automate the way your system
handles these.
And if you don't have a way to
address it, if you're missing
these values in your database,
then of course you can notify
the seller, or you can notify
some admin to address this
problem further.
So how can we do this with
client libraries?
Again using the Python client
library, if an error occurs,
the library, the request will
actually throw an error.
So, the gdata.client module
defines a request error class,
which is the class that is the
class of the exception.
If you insert the entry via
InsertProduct, wrap it in a
try accept loop, and actually
try to catch this exception, a
member of this class of
exceptions, right?
If you don't do this, and you're
running a long running
process that does all your
inventory updates and inserts
and deletes, this will
kill the process.
The stack trace will come, and
all of a sudden your inventory
is out of sync and you don't
have this process anymore.
So it's really important to
wrap these in try accept
statements.
If we didn't catch it in the
variable e x c, we can get the
error response as a string from
the body attribute of
that exception variable.
Now in order to parse that
into something we can
understand, we use the
atom.core module.
Now this module comes installed
with the g data dot
content for shopping
modules as well.
And using the parse function
within this module, we can
parse the error response
string into a
class of our choosing.
So here we have a predefined
class, gdata.contentfor
shopping.data.co
ntentforshoppingerrors.
And so we get a list of errors
as we saw on the last slide,
which was just a list
of those two errors
for price and condition.
That assumes your system knows
what's happening and can
actually deal with the
errors in real time.
Well, what happens if all of a
sudden you're going along, you
have 5% failure rate, you're
dealing with it and then next
thing you know, 80% of your
requests are failing.
This can happen.
Sometimes you can have a
recommended attribute all of a
sudden become a required
attribute.
And now those warnings, as you
didn't send a recommended
attribute, will become
actual errors.
So if you don't have some way
to account for this in your
system, what do you do?
If you're not logging it,
you just don't know
what's going on, right?
Well, we actually offer
something called the Debugging
Dashboard, which will allow you
to retrospectively look
back at all these requests
and figure out
what the issues were.
So here I am on the API
Dashboard for Joe's Widgets,
and we see some possible
errors.
So we see you didn't send a
required attribute, or you
tried to delete something that
wasn't found, or update that
something that wasn't found.
And what's more, we actually
provide sample requests that
will result in these errors.
For example, item is missing or
required attribute, I see
the body of the request that I
sent and the response that I
got in return, so it's
the same error.
Condition and price
are missing.
OK?
So what's more, we can fix this
within this dashboard by
using the Replay Request
functionality.
So if I want to replay this
request, let's not change it.
I have the same body
that was sent.
Let's replay it and
see what happens.
OK, so I click Replay Request,
we scroll down, and we see the
same error message, an account
of the areas that we have.
Condition, item is missing from
a required attribute.
Price, this item is
missing, right?
OK, so let's add in condition.
We can actually edit the request
within this dashboard
to fix our bug.
So let's say it's new.
I'm adding in this new
condition, and let's replay
that request.
OK, our error count has gone
down from two to one, but we
still are missing price, the
last required attribute.
So I'm going to add that in now,
scp price, with a unit of
US dollars, and a value of
25, and see what happens.
So let's replay this request.
OK, we have success.
And rather than this error
response, we get back the
response that we expect, this
automated response containing
the similar data from
the request.
One last thing I want to note
about this tool is they're
being sent in dry run mode.
So what does this mean?
If this bug, if this error
occurred two weeks ago, and
then I fix it with some dummy
data like I just did here,
well, I don't want to actually
officially insert that
product, this two-week-old
data, right?
That would be bad for my account
and it would be bad
for the users who go to buy this
product, which actually
is based on old data.
So this runs in dry run mode,
meaning the server, the API
server, will check whether
it's good or not.
And it'll tell you if you did it
if you did it right, if it
validates, but it won't actually
make the persistent
update to your database.
So that's a almost necessary
feature of this replay request
feature in the debug
dashboard.
Those were errors.
And these are things that
are very clear,
what's going to occur.
But like I said in that Debug
Dashboard, you could have some
things that all of a sudden
used to be recommendations
that become requirements.
And before they become errors,
they may have been warnings.
Like I showed in the demo tool,
you can actually specify
a warnings parameter and get
back warnings to again improve
the quality of your data.
And it's as simple as taking
that post request, not
changing the authentication
token that you're signing it
with, not changing the content
type, but simply appending the
warnings query parameter
to the end of the
string of the URI.
And what you'll get in return in
the app control element of
the entry that gets returned,
you'll get a Warnings block
containing a list of warnings,
which will give you things
like, hey, you're missing
a recommended
attribute like brand.
And what's the message.
We recommend including
this attribute.
Again, our client libraries
support this feature.
You can access these warnings
very simply.
For example, in Python, when
you're doing this insert
request, you can simply send the
warnings keyword parameter
and specify the Boolean
value of true.
And that will notify the client,
the client object,
that it needs to add on that
warnings query parameter to
the end of the URI when it's
making the request to the API.
And what you'll receive in
return, in the control
attribute of the returned value
inserted product, you'll
again have a sub-attribute
called warnings.
And this mimics the
exact structure of
the XML that we saw.
The inserted product
is the entry.
The control is that app
control element.
And then, finally,
warnings is that
sub-element with an app control.
You can loop through these
warnings and print out the
code, the domain, the location,
and the message.
So if we would have done that
for the warnings we saw on the
previous slide, we'd see
something like this.
We are missing a recommended
attribute.
That attribute is brand.
And what's the message?
We don't recommend including
this attribute.
So you can use things like this
in your implementation to
actually find out when changes
are going to occur, or how you
can actually improve.
If it's a recommended attribute,
it's recommended
for a reason.
This data actually will help
your users and the people
shopping for your data
on Google Shopping.
Finally, after we've talked
about errors and then
warnings, there's actually a
third type of, not really
error nor warning, that's
actually quite relevant to
your product data.
And I'm just going to
call that an issue
for the time being.
What are these issues?
These issues are things
that aren't
caught during your request.
They're not bad enough so that
your request gets rejected and
errors are returned, and they're
not glaring enough to
be included in this warnings
block even in the case of a
successful request.
So what are they?
First, your landing page
could be unavailable.
In order to keep the API fast,
we're not going to take your
data, go check if the landing
page for the product is
available and working, and then
come back and service
your request and give
you the response.
Rather, we'll just validate the
data, make sure it fits a
certain number of
qualifications, and then we'll
give you your response.
And this keeps it fast, right?
But we do want to go to
your web page and
find out if it's working.
Because, again, if
somebody finds a
product in product search--
excuse me, in Google
Shopping--
and they then try to go to a
page that doesn't work, that's
a terrible experience for
them and may harm their
relationship with you further
down the road when they're
shopping for other products.
In addition, there are things
like trademark violations,
which you can't detect possibly
in 500 seconds, but
you can do this machine
processing that Mayuresh was
talking about earlier to
actually find these out, and
find out where a trademark
might be infringed upon.
Another possible example,
similar to this trademark
violation, is your
categorization of your product.
It's possible that you've
called some
electronics a shoe.
And obviously someone who's
searching for electronics
doesn't want to find shoes,
unless they're Back to the
Future-style shoes
that can actually
tie themselves, right?
They're actual electronics.
This is something that within a
few hundred milliseconds we
can't detect, but after actually
going through the
data and doing some high level
machine processing, we can do
a decent job categorizing
the product.
We can find out if you've
done it incorrectly.
And finally, an issue, which
is really an umbrella of
issues, is that the data
you've submitted has a
discrepancy with the actual
data on your site.
So, for example, the price is
incorrect, or the description
is incorrect, or maybe
the color is wrong.
These sort of discrepancies,
again, reduce the quality of
the experience for your shoppers
and the users of
Google Shopping.
So what can you do about this?
How can you identify these
issues and improve the quality
of your data?
As some might know, we have data
quality dashboard in the
Merchant Center.
But what if you're using the
API and you never go to the
Merchant Center.
Or, what if you're a marketplace
and you have
hundreds of sub-sellers.
Well, you can't go to the data
quality API for hundreds of
sub-sellers to analyze
what's going on.
Instead, we have the
data quality API.
And this is a service very
similar to the items service
that we talked about earlier,
which will allow you to get
these data quality reports
programmatically through the
API, and it's very similar.
It's structured XML as
we'll see shortly.
And this is a supplement
to errors and warnings.
This is sort of the second
stage error.
These issues that happened that
maybe aren't detected as
errors, maybe aren't detected
as warnings, but really are
huge issues for the quality
of your data.
So in order to get this report
back, we don't have to worry
about posts or puts
or deletes.
We're not actually changing
any data.
We're just retrieving data.
So we make a get request, get,
the HTTP verb, corresponding
to retrieval.
We start off with the same
similar boilerplate,
content.googleap
is.com/content/v1, and then
after v1 we include
an account ID.
Now, if you don't have a
multi-client account, this
could just be your account.
But if this is a multi-client
account, this would
be the parent ID.
And then after that, we include
data quality, and that
identifies the service
within the API that
we're trying to reach.
And then we include another
account ID.
And now, again, if you're just
a single account, you'll just
repeat the first value, but in
the case of a multi-client
account where you're trying to
retrieve the report for one of
your some accounts, you would
make that a sub-account.
And then, of course, you're
signing it the same way, and
we're still requesting XML.
We know that the response we get
from Google will be XML,
so we identify the content
type in the same fashion.
So what will the response look
like from this request.
As I mentioned, it's XML.
It's going to be an entry just
like products are, but in that
entry, the data looks
a bit different.
I have commented out stuff
with this dot, dot, dot.
We have similar things like
title, published, edited,
these links, but the actual
report comes within this
element issue groups.
This is a list of issue groups
with some identifying
information like the country,
and the ID of the issue, the
ID here, US price mismatch.
And then within that, we
actually have specific issues.
The sample I have here has
an ID of price mismatch.
And it also has the time it was
last checked by Google.
So it was last checked, it
actually tells you a time when
the discrepancy, the price
mismatch, occurred.
And then finally, it tells you
the number of items that you
have which are suffering
from this issue.
And then, what's more, we
actually include an example,
so you can actually see
specifically what kinds of
things are causing this issue.
A price mismatch is
pretty clear how
that would come about.
This example, we have
the value on
landing page attribute.
So the value on landing
page 2.36.
I'm going to guess since it's
a US price mismatch, that's
probably $2.36, but it's 2.36
whatever the currency is.
And the submitted value, the
value that was actually
submitted to us via
the API, is 6.99.
Obviously, someone would like to
know that the price is 2.36
rather than when they come
through the search results and
they see 6.99, right?
So this is an issue.
And this is something
you can address.
And you could see, OK,
we have 57 items
that we need to address.
In summary, the data
quality tools you
have at your disposal.
First, errors, these errors you
can address immediately,
or actually have an admin deal
with if you don't have a way
to programmatically
deal with them.
Next, warnings, this is a
great tool for you to
continually improve your data
and listen to possible
suggestions that we have
to make it better.
Third, you debug dashboard, this
is huge in cases like I
mentioned before where something
goes wrong and you
weren't accounting for it.
And, finally, as we just
discussed, the data quality
API to get programmatic access
to a wonderful report that can
help you improve things
that are caught
after the initial request.
So with that I'm going
to conclude the talk.
The demo tool I demo'd can be
accessed online by any of you,
and you go through
the same thing.
Our documentation, it can be
found on developers.googl
e.com/shopping-content.
If you'd like these links,
they'll be in the description
of the YouTube video.
If you'd like to go get them
right now, this slide deck is
public on the web at
goo.gl/t5wZp as you can see
right here.
And these links are
in the slide
deck for you to retrieve.
Again, that's goo.gl/t5wZp.
I want to thank you for coming
today and I hope you enjoyed
this discussion.